[Musique]
les sénateurs agissent
la mission d'information du sénat appel
à lever le pass vaccinale
dès le début des débats parlementaires
sur le projet de loi instaurant le pass
vaccinale le sénat a cherché à vérifier
l'adéquation de cet instrument à
l'évolution de l'épidémie de kobe de 19
à cet effet il a créé une mission
d'information au sein de la commission
des affaires sociales doté des
prérogatives d'une commission d' enquête
chantal de seine olivier henno et michel
meunier rapporteurs se sont ainsi vivre
et un contrôle de cohérence des
décisions gouvernementales
jeudi 24 février 2022 ils ont présenté
les conclusions de leur rapport
alors que les projections de l'évolution
de l'épidémie laissaient craindre de
fortes tensions sur le système de soins
le gouvernement a souhaité transformer
le pass sanitaire en passe vaccinale
pour accroître l'incitation à la
vaccination
les rapporteurs relève que les annonces
gouvernementales ont été suivies d'une
augmentation significative de
l'administration de doses de vaccins
toutefois elles n'ont pas permis de
cibler en priorité les personnes non
vaccinées les plus susceptibles de
développer une forme grave
en outre le suivi quantitatif et
qualitatif des effets du pass vaccinale
reste insuffisant pour évaluer son
incidence sur la maîtrise de l'épidémie
pendant toute la durée de leur mission
les rapporteurs se sont aussi intéressés
au processus de décision
sur ce point il déplore la substitution
du conseil de défense au conseil des
ministres et donc la soustraction de la
décision au jeu normal des institutions
il aurait ainsi souhaité une plus grande
transparence dans la gestion de la
pandémie
à présent il paraît nécessaire
d'équilibrer et d'alléger les mesures
tout en préservant le système de santé
c'est pourquoi les rapporteurs appel à
la levée du pass vaccinale sans délai
mais avec prudence
ainsi les conditions de la réversibilité
de la décision devront être établies en
cas par exemple d'apparition d'un
nouveau variant dangereux
enfin la levée du pass vaccinale ne
serait pas synonyme de lever du pass
sanitaires dans les hôpitaux ni de
l'obligation vaccinale pour les
soignants
pour en savoir plus consultez les
conclusions de la mission d'information
[Musique]